Hello, everybody.
Hold on.
Wait.
There we go.
Actually, hold on.
Let me remove some stuff around.
That's better.
Yippee!
Welcome.
Oh, I forgot to say.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome back to Oblivion.
Oh, gosh.
It's been so long since I played.
It's been so long.
Well, now I remember how to kill people.
Wow, it's your first time playing Oblivion?
It is.
Yeah.
So, uh, yeah.
Hope you're feeling good today.
I am.
I'm feeling pretty good.
I'm feeling, I'm feeling okay.
Um, yeah.
I'm feeling okay.
And, uh, I'm ready to, to play.
What was I gonna say?
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like... I feel so out of it.
I feel so, like...
Hold on.
When I don't stream consistently...
My brain forgets how...
To stream...
Just watch the new MGS Delta video.
Oh, my God.
Me too.
I watched it earlier.
If you guys haven't seen it.
They had...
My Oshi, actually.
They had my Oshi in the video.
So, Konami put out a thing for Delta.
And they got, like, some people that were involved in Delta.
To...
Like, talk about it and stuff.
Of...
And...
My Oshi.
Her name is Ruby Taki.
And she's...
She's, like...
The best ever...
Metal Gear...
Cosplayer...
Ever.
She's so...
Oh, my gosh.
If you never...
Just Google Ruby Taki.
And...
If you see...
A Metal Gear Rex.
She made that.
Mental health fun.
Thank you.
Yeah.
She's crazy.
She's so awesome.
I love her.
I have her pictures...
On my fridge.
I love her stuff so much.
Yeah.
So, I'm...
I'm a...
I'm a Minimal fan.
And when I saw her, I was like...
She's there.
If anybody deserves it, she does.
I will miss Deer Stage.
I also miss the milk shop at the Akiba Station platform.
Wait, stop.
I don't...
I haven't seen new Akiba Station yet.
No spoilers.
I haven't seen it yet.
You're one of her fans.
Yeah, I'm a big fan.
I'm a big fan.
I'm excited.
For Delta.
I was...
So...
I...
Um...
What was it?
The...
Oh, the people...
So...
Konami has been sending out...
PR boxes to people...
For Metal Gear.
And...
Um...
I saw...
I saw Maddie.
My friend Maddie.
She was like...
Oh, I'm kind of jealous of people getting those boxes.
And I've been like...
Kind of trying not to...
To look at any of them.
Because I was like...
Oh, I don't know...
Fingers crossed, maybe.
Maybe I'll just...
I'll just check my...
I'll be a little more diligent checking my email or something.
And then I saw a post...
Today.
And I was like...
Oh...
Maddie commented on it.
I saw...
Also...
Someone else...
A couple other people were just like...
Oh, I kind of want one.
And then they sent them to...
To them.
But I'm a little few days late.
So I was like...
Well, you know what?
Let me just shoot my shot.
And that was like...
There were so many people that responded.
Being like...
Meant to get a box.
I was like crying about it.
I'm going to cry about it again.
Because I was like...
You guys didn't have to do that.
So...
I was like...
Oh...
So...
If I get one...
Thank you guys.
Of course I will...
Show it off for you guys.
And everything.
I'll offer my Kamiyoshi...
My vocal cords.
No...
Ender!
Dude!
I saw you notice...
My handiwork...
At the PAX East...
Info booth.
Oh!
The plushie.
I've been working there...
For 10 years now.
And I always...
Try to have a little mascot...
There to entertain...
The attendees one year.
It was some...
Weirdo elf...
That I strapped to a toy...
Horse.
Oh!
Was she...
A cowboy?
They're actually just gonna send you...
Snake in a box.
I hope...
They send me...
A live snake.
And they say...
Prove your loyalty.
Eat the snake.
If you love snakes so much...
Why don't you eat it?
Then I'll be like...
Okay...
Thank you for the re...
Thank you for the redirect...
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Hello, hello.
Sorry, I'm talking about eating snakes.
But yeah...
So that happened this morning...
And I was just like...
Oh, you guys...
Maybe they'll notice me.
Maybe they'll be like...
Oh, man.
This girl's...
Got some really loud fans.
Can't say goodbye to yesterday...
It's over 100k views.
Thank you!
Guys for...
Thank you so much...
For watching it.
I know it's not like the...
You know...
It's not like a...
Like a...
A song that is so popular...
That people would always...
Click and listen to.
So I really appreciate...
That it's at...
100k views.
Thank you!
And...
Um...
I also released a cover yesterday...
That...
Is at 50k views.
So thank you!
Thank you.
I just kind of put out...
I actually was supposed to schedule it...
Earlier and then...
I forgot...
Eat that snake.
Yeah!
I'll eat it.
Bones and all.
Yesterday's was a jump scare.
Well, I gotta keep you guys on your toes.
I only...
Have one more cover planned.
Oh, I still have to record it though.
So...
So it might be a little bit more time.
Plus the music video is not...
Finished for it either.
But all the animation and stuff is finished for it.
That one will probably also be a jump scare.
Hmm.
Whenever I get to record it.
Right now I have too many other things to record.
And my voice is still kind of...
So I will wait for a little bit longer before...
I can record it.
Nah.
Hehehe.
I want you guys to know though...
Half...
Part of me resting is also so that...
I can...
Do things...
Like...
So...
I'm not like putting a pause on all...
The activities I have going on.
Like part of the resting is so that...
I don't burn my voice out...
All day...
Hehehe.
From streaming.
And then I can't record other things.
So...
Do the do.
Hehehe.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
That's kind of part of it.
So...
There will be other things that will...
Um...
Be happening.
Something's me...
I don't want to say any more.
Hahaha.
I don't want to say anything...
More...
Actually...
I should start playing the game, huh?
Because...
I have some meetings tonight...
That I...
I...
Okay.
I'm so stupid.
They were like...
Let's meet at...
6 p.m...
PST.
And I was like...
Okay.
3 p.m...
E.S.T.
Hahaha.
Oopsy.
Oopsie.
So...
Hahaha.
I...
That's why I had to move the stream a little bit.
Because I was like...
Hehehehe.
3 p.m.
EST.
And then it became 3 p.m.
And I was like, where are they?
I think they're late.
I hope they're not watching right now, because this would be so bad.
If they're like, oh, we heard that you wait.
But yeah.
And then, later this week, I leave for Japan.
I'll be gone for a little bit.
But you will see me on Coyote's 3D Graduation Live.
Concert?
And so, you'll see me then.
And I'll try to do some Twitter spaces.
While I'm gone.
I just wail.
And probably a 24-hour stream thingy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Still have a collab with Coyote this week?
Yes.
Tomorrow morning, my time.
10 a.m.
EST.
Well, I don't know what we're playing yet.
Minto Health No.
1.
Opportunities Projects No.
2.
Stream No.
3.
Opportunities and Projects No.
1.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the Augustine, but thank you.
After 5 months of absent interviews, I finally have a new job.
Let's go!
Oh my gosh.
Congratulations!
Congrats!
Wait.
Discard Capitor.
So gross!
Wait, that's such a clever name.
Congratulations!
Sorry.
I can't...
I can't hear my voice.
It's kind of...
Not so great today.
So let's just...
Continue.
Oh wait.
Load?
E-Tina.
Uy.
Safe travels, Minky.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
So tomorrow will just be me and...
I will just have the stream...
I don't know if I actually will stream.
It will depend on what game we play.
But uh...
This might be streamed for this week.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I will win for Minky.
I will win for all of us.
Cease those...
Cease?
Thank you, Tuna.
Stop those activities.
Cease.
Okay.
We're here.
We just joined the...
The...
The sisterhood...
Brotherhood.
Of darkness.
Cease.
Oh yeah, I stopped right on this view.
Yeah, this is the town that I want to live in.
But...
People were telling me...
That there is...
A haunted house.
In Anvil?
Was it?
Anvil.
The sisterhood of a brotherhood.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
I want a haunted house.
But we also have to go kill some pirates.
Maybe I'll go do that now.
Right?
Wait, quests.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I got fantasy life.
Sorry I'm not streaming it.
I kind of wanted to just have a game...
That I can play at my own pace.
And...
I'm a fisher.
Go to the waterfront...
And gain access to the pirate ship.
Oh, we gotta kill the captain.
Yeah, I might have to be in one of the crates.
Okay.
Wait, I'm gonna fast travel to there.
Can I?
Yes.
So, I got it.
But I got it for the Switch.
But people were telling me...
That you can...
Okay, so I got it for the Switch.
Because obviously the original fantasy life was the...
Was the 3DS, right?
And I got it.
Because I was like...
Oh man...
I...
Just...
It just felt right.
I don't know.
The haunted house is cheap too.
It's the only house I could ever afford in a...
I mean...
Dang.
Wait, I kind of want to hear them sing.
Good morning.
No, no, no.
This guy always sings for us.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of Wayrest.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of mine.
I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of Wayrest.
So fun.
Fuck.
Want to show off my new profile picture by Tuna?
It looks great, Liam.
Oh, wait.
You believe you could effectively hide in this crate...
And then be transported to the pirate ship.
Marie Alina, do you wish to hide in the crate?
Or try to find your own way aboard the ship?
I could hide in the crate.
Fantasy life would be cool for swimming...
But a few months are going to be weird.
Yeah.
I just wanted...
Also, I'm going to play the heck out of it on the plane.
Congrats on the cover.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to jump scare you guys.
But thank you for listening to it.
And please keep listening to it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hide in the crate.
Just a crate.
Gaston.
Oh my gosh, we have to kill Gaston.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, how do I get my weapon out?
Wait, how do I get my...
Wait.
How do I get my weapon out?
What's the...
What's the key?
Oh, I thought it was one.
What is it?
Oh no.
Wait, I have a...
Am I fine?
Wait.
Which one's better?
Oh, they're both the same.
Iron arrow.
Wait, no.
Steel arrow.
Okay.
F.
Quick save.
Thank you, guys.
Okay.
I'm here.
And I'm sneaking.
Why is the music...
The music is way too calm for what I'm about to do.
The music is way too like...
Lala.
You are in a journey.
What is this?
What's the point of this room?
Where's your Capitan?
I think I know what's full in that sack.
There's just...
There's peanuts.
15th was my birthday.
Happy birthday, KC.
Sorry for it being delayed.
Happy, happy birthday.
Hold on.
I don't want to open more stuff.
Fur...
Gauntlet.
This is where I was at.
Oh, gosh.
That probably stank.
They have nothing in here.
Alright.
I quicksaved.
Wait.
Let me quicksave again.
For my fursuit.
Yeah.
Wait.
There's a lockpick?
Did I miss it?
Oh.
Good eye.
More beans.
Wait.
Gosh, they got a lot of sacks in the end.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Wait.
Mid deck.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Oh.
Oh, it autosaved.
Why'd it do that?
Wooden door.
Someone's diary.
Oh, it's about Morrowind.
Okay.
I'm telling you, lad.
It's bad luck.
A woman on board a pirate vessel.
Back in my day, it never would have happened.
Uh-oh.
Captain Tussaud keeps her on for...
Hold there, laddie!
Are they upstairs?
That guy sounded like right next to us.
She may be tougher than me.
And Mina, too.
No girls allowed.
That's not even possible.
All right.
I told you a million times it wasn't my fault.
The wheel was covered with gull droppings.
I can't tell if they're here.
Okay, let's go try...
I don't...
Okay, we're looking for Gaston, everybody.
Someone's bed.
Ah, dang.
We could take their food.
Have them starve.
This place is...
This place is barnacles!
I could sleep in their bed.
What if I just kill the whole crew, though, you know?
The door's open!
Who opened it?
Behind me?
No?
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared right now.
Wait.
I see somebody there on the bed.
I think that's our man.
There we go.
Oops.
One moment.
Oh, shoot.
It was just a pirate.
Oh, here they come.
I'll get their hand.
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, God.
I'm so dead.
Kill him!
Ow!
I can't move!
Oh, gosh.
Yeah!
Die!
Die, pirate!
This ends here!
Gosh.
Take all my arrows back.
I thought you were the captain!
Oh, golly.
Okay, well, so much for that.
Take his fancy cutlass.
It's heavy.
It's heavy, though.
She's got a pickaxe.
What are you?
Steve?
Capitan!
This music is really...
Just not the mood here.
Where the hell is the captain?
And where's all your money?
Worst pirates of the seven seas.
This ends here.
Instantly dies.
Oh.
See?
I was looking at the marker.
And it said...
Like, five steps here.
So I assumed...
It...
Here we go.
I must now kill Gaston Toussaint.
I hear a worm...
Oh, what was that?
What was that?
Is that him on the table?
Oh, I think that is.
No kidding?
What if he wants to talk?
Yeah, the book moved by itself.
Green arrow means it's him.
Ah, I see.
I don't think he does.
You can talk to him.
You're not in the Brotherhood of Yapping.
But like...
His booty is very hard.
Fall of the Snow Prince is a literature man.
Oh, he sees me.
100%.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Wait.
What?
Um...
Oh, I don't want to pick your pockets.
Sorry.
Or in blazes.
You ain't one of me crew.
You best start explaining yourself, mate.
If you want to get off this ship alive.
This is the captain.
He barely looks like a pirate.
Say nothing.
Justice is at hand, pirate.
The Dread Father summons you.
Thank you.
Ah, what are you?
Some kind of preacher or something?
One of them crazies from the church?
I ain't got time for this.
Oh, shoot.
Let me get my thing out.
Oh, my God.
He's fast.
Oh, shoot.
I need to actually hit him.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Take that.
It does.
With you.
You'll never take...
Well, that'll never take away.
Gaston is now dead.
I must now return to the sanctuary and speak with V-Vincent Valtteri to receive my reward.
Oh, hi, dog, baby.
He has it!
The Lusty Arc Guardian made!
The book!
The fu- Wait.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Where is it?
I love so many things.
Oh, here we go.
What is the warp in the west?
When did I grab that?
What do you mean it's only three pages?
Act...
Four...
Scene three...
Continued.
Lifts her tail.
Is that her name?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha!
Golly.
Lifts her tail.
Certainly not kind, sir.
I am here but to clean your chambers.
Crantius Cullto.
Is that all you have come here for, little one?
My chambers?
Lifts her tail.
I have no idea what it is you imply, master.
I am but a poor Argonian maid.
So you are my dumpling.
And a good one at that.
Such strong legs and shapely tail.
You embarrass me, sir.
Fear not.
You are safe here with me.
I must finish my cleaning, sir.
The mistress will have my head if I do not.
Cleaning, eh?
I have something for you.
Here, polish my spear.
But it's huge!
It could take me all night.
Plenty of time, my sweet.
Plenty of time.
That's it!
Wait, is there more?
Or...
How does this rate against the other monster romance books?
Pretty...
Pretty average.
This is typical.
This is standard, you know?
I'll keep this on me.
Uh oh.
Wait, is that a door?
Wait, where are they?
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
No, no, no.
I'm just a... I'm just a lusty maid.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Where's your lady friend?
Is she gonna come down too?
I'm scared.
Okay.
Whew.
Take this damn route.
Nice.
Yay.
Guys, I was... I'm not being serious.
It's because of the book.
I was trying to be like... Oh, some grapes.
I was trying to... make them be like...
I'm supposed to be here, you know?
Why did they sound like they were coming from over here?
Is this a door?
Oh, it is.
It's a city aisle.
Oh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Before we do that though...
Let's try this... very hard...
Oh!
I don't need to try it at all.
I have a key.
Oh!
Oh yeah.
Take it all.
Remove the top first.
Reach inside and take out all the parts.
Being careful to note their order.
Put the carving onto the rod.
Reinsert the rod into the cavity.
Replace the parts in the order you remove them.
Seal the top with pine tar.
I got his booty!
I be plundering.
Stop!
You viol...
I didn't violate the law, they're pirates!
Whatever you say.
Miss lifts her frills!
Sounds like part two of the book.
What is this?
What is it?
I feel like it's important.
He's peacefully sleeping.
Maybe he has the rest of the book.
This is the other one that's pretty sleazy, right?
The real Bear and Zarya.
Okay.
His drawers...
I think I can leave now.
Maybe he rode it?
Okay.
I...
Was there another...
Way out?
Or...
Oh!
Wait, why don't I go to that one and...
Oh, it's a sword.
Instead of this one.
What's the difference?
Actually, where did I come...
Oh, I came from here.
Okay.
You could have made a stealthy exit.
Yeah, but then I couldn't kill him.
You have the key.
Oh, so true.
Okay, you're right.
Okay.
We're gonna be stealthy.
And leave.
Nobody's gonna spot us.
Is that my horse?
No, my horse is fancy.
I remember.
Those...
Poor, stupid pirates up there.
Ew!
What's in here?
That's why you should always search through the trash.
We did it!
Stupid pirates.
Stupid.
Did you know that I'm your captain now?
They don't even know.
Oh, I think the other door would have led right there.
Oh, that would have been so bad.
That would have been...
Not ideal.
Medieval dumpster diving.
Yeah.
Where is my horse?
Hmm...
13 is a spooky number.
That's not my horse.
Yeah, I would have been greeted by that guy.
Do you think they know who I am?
Let's see.
They left it by some gate?
Probably.
Wait, they're not talking at all.
Hello?
Am I interrupting?
Are you a pirate?
Oh, where it?
Oh, where is...
Where is...
Oh, hey sweet lady of mine?
Oh, hey sweet lady of mine, I'll see you again, yes I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of way rest so fine.
They're still at it.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of my rest.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of mine.
Oh, I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of my rest so fine.
Can you spare a coin?
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's Pewdie!
Red god of courage and honor was he.
Say lo, my Cyrus, say lo.
Colovia is a land of rugged wastes and highland forest.
Why do they speak like that with their hands?
They say syndicates of wizards have led a boycott of imperial goods in the land of the Altma.
It seems Somerset Isle has become a much more dangerous place.
Why do they both talk like that?
Safe travels.
Oh, hey, sweet lady of my rest.
I like how he sings it.
Sweet lady of mine.
I'll see you again.
I'll also see you again.
Oh, sweet lady of my rest so fine.
Everybody's talking.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
I need to leave.
Everybody's talking.
All right.
So now we just got to go back to our home.
And then I'm going to go to Anvil.
And see how much we need.
The voices.
Puny.
Why would you name your kid that?
Did he just say make your kills be quick?
Wait, am I in the right place?
Yeah.
It's just really orange.
Oh, I thought he was pantsless for a second.
Just orc things.
Yeah.
Um.
We need to go.
Abandoned.
Abandoned home.
Oh, shoot.
Which one was it?
Stand clear.
What's wrong?
Whose house is this?
Alders.
Is this it?
Um.
Bye.
Be seeing you.
Oh.
Hello.
I'm Magician Orateur of the Mages Guild.
I divide my time between the Chadenhall Guild and my own private studies at Willowback.
Learn pickpocketing and you can pants the whole town.
I don't know how to pickpocket.
Not only has necromancy been banned from practice in the Mages Guild, but the guild won't deal with anyone who openly uses it.
Is your tongue okay?
I wanna learn necromancy.
Farewell.
Oh, he's looking at me?
Sorry.
What if I pickpocket that lady?
Go away.
Go away, Orateur.
Okay, here we go.
I think he will notice.
You think they'll notice?
Pickpocket!
Oops.
Um.
I've been suspended from the Mages Guild.
What does that mean?
What quest is this?
Make this my act...
It's like that lady...
Oh, hello.
That lady that was in, like, Italy that would be like...
Pickpocket!
Based on your skill and the value of item you try to...
I don't think he cared very much.
I think I got the money, you know?
Pickpocket!
What's my quest now?
Oh.
Well, what's my quest?
To go beg for forgiveness?
Or...
Did I take the bank key?
Actually, I don't know which one I took.
Hello.
You are suspended is the quest.
A Mages Guild.
Wait, hold on.
Which is the Mages Guild.
I don't have an arrow, so...
Mages Guild.
Are you?
Fighters Guild.
Magrum's House.
The March Rider.
An M.
Lodge.
I give up.
Oh.
Ah!
You violated the law.
Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
Your stolen goods are now forfeited.
I don't wanna...
Oh, it's only 25.
Stop!
You have violated the law!
Ah!
I didn't think he was running at me.
I thought nobody cared.
You lose any stolen items.
Wait, what do I have?
If I resist arrest...
I could always reload.
I think it's an autosave, probably.
You'll die.
I will...
Trust.
Trust!
Then pay with your blood!
Just.
But...
Who has another bow and arrow?
Oh, this is on fire.
I think I should leave.
Oh,
they totally... she sees me.
You can't hit me.
Ouch.
You hit me.
I'm running.
Go, you did a go.
The bell tolls for thee.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Where's my horse?
You guys stole my horse.
I think that is even more...
Okay.
I think I'm in trouble for real, you guys.
Last time, it was just one guy.
So...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna load my last...
Here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Wait, which is this autosave?
You think this is when I attack or after I thieved?
Load.
Let's see.
Okay.
I think we're okay.
Yeah, I think we're okay.
Okay.
Good.
Have mercy.
Just one...
We're free!
Wait, is this an entrance?
Let me in!
Is that the hero of Kvatch racing down the highway in a white bronco?
I am the hero of Kvatch.
I should be... I should be known as such.
I'm not getting the recognition I deserve.
You.
It's all your fault.
Oh.
I wasn't going to steal.
There's a bridge.
If you're just going to...
Who sees me?
Wait, what's that fire over there?
Oh.
I almost just didn't take my own advice.
Uh-oh.
Um...
It's on fire, the city.
Why can't... Why is it illegal to sit?
We see you.
This is why you quicksave before committing crimes.
Okay, I'm learning.
Stop!
You violated the law.
Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
What is it?
F7?
Your stolen goods are now forfeited.
Thanks for streaming while I pack my separate upcoming trip going to Anime North.
Ooh, have fun.
The eye was open.
It was closed.
F9.
Oh, okay.
That's too bad.
Okay.
F9.
I did quicksave, didn't I?
Oh yeah, I quicksaved right in front of you.
It's always...
It's your fault.
See?
It's not...
It's not open.
So I could grab anything I please.
Like his...
Key.
Flying...
Flying in the sky...
Cliff racer flies so high...
Flying...
What's wrong with him?
I used the key door.
Oh, he's drunk.
Stupid.
I'm trespassing.
Technically.
But...
I have a key.
So that means...
I must belong here.
Clearly.
I don't think there's anybody...
Wow, this place is...
Well!
They just keep their meat on the table.
Next to the strawberries.
Where's all their gold?
One measly gold.
Incident and necrom.
Ooh!
Artista!
Boar meat.
No!
Why doesn't anybody cook their meat in this game?
I hope the guy doesn't come home.
That would be really unfortunate.
Mage's Guild Char...
Oh yeah, this guy is part of the Mage's Guild.
That doesn't matter.
Unless I get caught.
Basement.
I still got it, baby.
Nyo-kun, thank you for your funds.
I love your profile picture.
Hope things get better for you.
Why doesn't anyone keep...
Big gold?
At all?
So disappointing, all these...
Richie rich folks.
With no riches.
Miu cute.
Yeah.
I prefer Saki, but I respect your opinion.
Because Miu is my second...
Well...
Oh my gosh, what's her name?
Glasses Girl in...
Sorry, I'm talking Blue Archive, you guys.
There's a Glasses Girl in...
Um...
In...
The Bunny Squad.
Oh boy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was...
I didn't like her so much.
Oh wait, is this...
No.
I'm still trying to find her...
Our home.
I didn't like her so much until she got the...
Bathing suit outfit.
And then I was like, okay.
I think it's because her initial art was just kind of like...
Something's off about it to me.
How can I help you today, friend?
But then I saw her...
With the bathing suit art.
And I was like, she's so cute.
Swear a coin for the infound.
Hail.
Hello.
What?
Everybody's gotta have...
To say something.
It's like those scenes in anime where...
Something happens and each person goes...
And they like change the...
To each person.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Let's just go to the quests and figure it out.
Which one was it?
Killing field?
No.
Oh, a watery grave.
There we go.
Inspect.
Open a map.
I'm like too...
Oh, it's right there.
Okay.
I'm right in front of it.
I see.
What are you watching?
You know those scenes in anime.
Something will happen.
Like something dramatic.
And then it'll like...
Each character when it zooms in on their face.
They'll go like...
Each time.
You'll notice it now that I've mentioned it.
You'll know.
They do that all the time.
It's a staple.
It is.
What are you talking about?
It's real.
I promise.
Okay.
Make a bet, everybody.
Will he have hair?
Excuse me, brother.
Can you spare a moment?
Will he wear wigs?
What is it?
Aw, man.
So, is it true about your latest contract?
The girl's nanny was actually a fighter's guild bodyguard?
Word certainly gets around fast, doesn't it?
Kyle, I think you're in the wrong place.
Antraneta has been running her mouth off again.
Anyway, nothing I couldn't handle.
Sometimes I wonder how you survive it all without me being there to watch your back.
Well, I should return to my duties.
Till next time, then.
Walk always in the shadow of Sittis.
Why do they do this?
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary, my newest sister.
Oh, okay, hold on.
Nice.
I don't play Blue Archive anymore, but my fave was Shiroko.
Shiroko, I love so much because she's voiced by my seiyuuoshi.
Hello, my sister.
Hello, my brother.
Brother.
So, the pirate has been eliminated.
I hate his hair.
I hate it.
No one will mourn his passing.
And Sittis has been appeased.
Please accept this black band as your reward.
It is a ring whose powers are quite useful to those who value discretion.
Cool.
Woo!
What did I get?
I've been meaning to speak with you.
But of course, what trouble?
Oh, black band.
Wait, what is it?
Is it like a ring?
Oh, it looks like a ring.
I can put on multiple rings.
I'm styling.
Nice.
I've been meaning to ask you about your last contract.
I heard there were some complications.
What's happening?
Wait, what's going on?
It certainly gets around fast, doesn't it?
Whoa!
Don't tell me.
Antoinette has been running her mouth off again.
Whoa!
Anyway, nothing I could unhandle.
You are truly an asset to this sanctuary.
I'm buffed.
Here's hoping all of our contracts work out that well.
Well, I should return to my duties.
Till next time, then.
Walk with darkness, child of the night mother.
Hello, my sister.
Oh, what just happened?
Are you okay?
I think you got...
I think you were collateral damage there.
Get away from me.
Oh, sorry.
RTX wisp.
Yeah.
Yeah, actually.
Wait, is this guy gonna follow me all the time now?
That's so cute.
Woohoo!
Okay, wait.
Can I get a new quest?
Or...
Guys, I really wanna kill those people.
I still wanna kill the paranoia people.
But I don't think I'm strong enough anymore.
I don't think I'm strong enough.
Clippers, please.
What?
What did I say?
Uh-oh.
Oh, hello.
Oh, Chiva.
I remember you.
Try poison.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
We can try...
We can try, like, better...
Wait, I'm trying to look for...
Vampire Man.
Is that you?
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary.
Thank you.
My newest sister.
Uh...
Someone here should sell some.
Okay.
Yeah, if we try poison arrows, it might be okay.
Did you?
No, that guy uses his fists.
That guy is not relying on...
Arrows.
That guy uses brute strength.
Let's see.
Where'd he go?
I think he hangs out down here.
No?
I can't believe he sleeps on a slab.
Look at the following.
Well, people will think I'm possessed or...
Oh, gosh.
Oh, he's here.
Hello, my sister.
Hello.
I'm glad you've returned.
The contract is waiting, if you're ready.
Okay.
Contract.
What we got?
We need you to stage an accident.
Kill the target in the mana specified, and you'll receive a considerable bonus.
Ooh.
Do you accept this contract?
Um, yes.
As I expected.
Good.
The target is a wood elf named Banelin.
You will find him at his home in Bruma.
Enter secretly and avoid his manservant, Grom.
On the second floor is a secret door leading to a crawl space.
Inside are the fastenings of a mounted head that hangs over Banelin's favorite chair.
Loosen those fastenings any night between 8 p.m.
and 11 p.m., and the head will surely fall on Banelin as he relaxes in his chair, as is his custom.
Wait, what do you mean?
If Banelin is eliminated in any other manner, or if the manservant bomb is killed, you will forfeit the bonus.
Now go, and may Scythus be with you.
Oh, wait.
What'd you say?
Sorry, I was...
Excuse me, brother.
I was too concerned with your hair.
She's so cool.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, I gotta read this again.
Stage a tragic accident.
Oh, shoot.
It's not telling me anything.
I...
Okay, so I can't kill Grom.
How am I supposed to kill him?
Okay.
Oh, you must mean the orphanage contract.
Uh-oh.
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary.
Thanks, thanks, thanks.
My newest sister.
Thank you.
Oh, I can't go out the key.
Yeah, that's right.
Ask again?
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Luckily, I have lots of stealth.
Yeah, yeah, through the holes.
Hello, my sister.
Brother, if I may have a word.
Yes, brother.
I've been meaning to ask you about...
Every moment that Bainlin draws breath is an affront to Scythus and the Night Mother.
Fulfill the contract and honor the Brotherhood as you should.
We saw it flickering.
Okay.
You are to travel to Bruma.
Oh.
Into the house of the Wood Elf Bainlin.
Wait, wait, I have to pay attention.
I have to pay attention.
It should look like an accident.
I'm sure you can handle it.
Wait.
He didn't explain anymore.
Make it look like an accident.
Surely.
Farewell, sister.
Surely they will.
They will.
I wish to welcome you to this sanctuary.
I welcome you to our family.
And this sanctuary.
To others?
Oh, okay, okay.
May you find yourself at home here.
In the loving embrace of our lady, the Night Mother.
What if we plant a...
A...
Um...
A bow and arrow in her arm?
I don't know.
If the target is old and weak, as you say, then his manservant is sure to be quite the opposite.
Oh.
Best stay out of his way.
Dude's quantum hair.
May Scythus be with you.
Yeah, that's true.
How could I make it look like an accident?
Mentioned a crawlspace.
Yes, he did.
He said on the second story.
Help me.
Yes, sister.
What can old Gogron do for you?
Gogron, give me some advice.
The manservant's name is Grom, you say.
Sounds like a Nord.
Probably a big one.
If he catches you, get ready for a serious fight.
Yeah.
Later then.
Mm-hmm.
Is she still...
Greetings, sister.
I do hope you are well.
Otiva, help me.
If things go badly, forgo the plan and simply kill the mark any way you can.
You'll lose the bonus.
But at least the contract will be fulfilled.
Ah, okay.
She's like, just murder.
Go now, dear family member, and may the night mother wrap you in her cold, loving embrace.
Thank you.
Is this little guy gonna get in the way of my stealth?
My little ghost pal?
Wise otiva.
Yes.
It will!
Welcome dear sister, so good to finally meet you.
Oh my gosh.
I hope you're getting along all right.
If you need anything, anything at all, you need only ask.
Yes, it's a bright light.
Shoot.
How do you plan on entering this man's house?
Through the front door?
Be smart and look for a more inconspicuous way in.
Like a cellar entrance.
She's got crazy eyes.
I'll be seeing you then.
Wow, she's...
Oh my gosh.
Get out of the way.
Can I?
You again?
I thought I'd made it clear.
They're like, bad codec.
If you're here to buy or sell something, get on with it already.
Oh, I can buy from you.
That's right.
Um...
I see this I don't have all day.
Hurry up.
Do you have any poison arrows?
Steel arrows.
Arrow of cowardice.
No.
Bow of infernal frost.
Neat.
I can fix her.
Foul smelling ape.
Excuse me, brother.
Can you spare a moment?
Yes, brother.
I've been meaning to ask you about your last contract.
I heard there was some complication.
I can't believe...
World certainly gets around fast, doesn't it?
I can't believe he's bald again.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Let's go try this contract, I guess.
I think they're in the city, so we don't have to go so far.
Make sure to get the bonus.
I'll try.
I would like to get the bonus, yes.
Let's...
Oh, yeah.
Let's take off my ring.
And then it's...
Black water-sized stables.
If that guy can do it, so can I.
It's not illegal to go in the water, is it?
How goes it?
Hello.
Is this a fighter's guild?
The stables.
How are you?
Outside?
Okay.
Austin, Nadia.
Thank you so much for the Valkryptor.
Thank you.
All right.
It's in another city.
Oh, it is?
No kidding.
Reading the number helps.
Um, the number said 60 steps.
What are you talking about?
Huh?
It 100% said 60 steps.
Well.
Hmm.
Where is it then?
60 to get out of the city.
Yeah.
Yeah, I discovered that now.
What's awaited quests.
City of Bruma.
Bruma.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, there it is.
I was like...
Isn't there supposed to be an arrow?
So if I travel to the stables, maybe my horse will join.
Thank you for the soup?
You're welcome.
Okay, it's 3 a.m.
Perfect time.
Probably they go into this guy's house and murder him.
What if I do want to enter through the front door?
All right.
I save.
I think that was the sound of my pickpocketing level up.
Oops.
Okay, time to sneak.
I have entered Bane Lin's house.
If I can access the second floor crawl space and loosen the fastenings on the mounted head between 8 p.m.
and 11 p.m.
It will fall on Bane Lin as he rests in his chair.
Do I need to come back?
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, so I have to be there at 8 to 11?
Where's the door?
You can just wait on the second floor.
But like that...
I think I might get caught, no?
Hide in the crawl space.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I quick save.
Oh, I saved.
So if we die here, we'll be right outside.
It's okay.
Okay.
Either...
Okay, Grom is asleep.
Okay, actually, this is perfect.
No?
They're both asleep.
Now, where was the crawl space?
Nice.
And also, what?
This one, maybe?
Um...
In Grom's room.
Close the door?
Uh-huh.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, nice.
Totally fine that we're here.
Now, we wait...
Okay.
It's 5 a.m.
6...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
This will be 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17...
Wait.
8...
10...
Wait.
Oh.
You need 20.
Well, 20 o'clock is 8 o'clock.
But that's starting from 12, no?
I didn't start from 12.
I started from 5.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Okay.
So, it was...
8 to 11.
So, this should be fine.
We're waiting all day and waiting all night.
Waiting to murder.
Okay, we just wait a couple minutes.
8-0-1.
Activate.
These appear to be the fastenings of the mounted minotaur head.
As expected, they have been loosened over time.
You could easily remove the fastenings causing the mounted head to crash in the floor below.
Do you wish to remove the fastenings?
Yes.
The mounted head has fallen on Bain Lin, killing him as expected.
I must return to the sanctuary and speak with Vincent Baltieri to receive my reward.
Nice.
Good job, team.
Wait, so, uh...
Question.
Can I fast travel from here or do I have to leave?
Tsundurathos.
Thank you so much for the 20th gift.
Thank you!
Gotta sneak out.
Wait, we can try?
Let's see.
You cannot fast travel from this location.
Okay.
All right, well, I just saved, so...
Surely he's gonna be all, like...
Concerned with this...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
He's totally gonna see me.
You guys are already saved.
Oh, my sneak increased.
Actually, perfect timing.
Okay.
Ikimasu!
The eyeball opened for a tad second.
Where's the door?
Get me out of here!
Yeah!
I am the Brotherhood's best...
Bestest.
Sithis loves me the mostest.
How are you?
Oh, I just killed the guy in there.
What?
Oh.
You gotta make up your mind.
Hi there.
Hello.
Let's go home.
And then after this one, I'm gonna go to Anvil.
And we're gonna see...
Maybe after this, I will have enough money.
We'll see.
We'll see, we'll see.
But after this, we'll...
Um, go to Anvil and see if I can...
Buy a house.
Tell everybody of your work.
I'm quite proud of it, so...
I think everybody should...
Be proud of their work, no?
I have a feeling I'm going the wrong way.
That was really smooth.
Thank you!
It's like I was born...
To be...
To be like this.
I was born to be evil.
Um...
Greetings to you.
Cool.
Evil.
All right.
Let's go, guys.
Good stuff.
Born to live in the walls.
Call me.
Who lives in the walls?
Excuse me, brother.
Can you spare a...
Hello, top of the morning.
How are you?
Great, Mr. Guard.
I just murdered a guy.
I didn't even ask you about the last contract.
Oh, greeting.
Termites.
Call me.
Mintomite.
Well, it's true.
The children actually tried to defend themselves.
Poor dears.
Wait, I thought the other guy had the contract.
So, the accident has been staged and Banelin lies dead.
Well done.
You have more than earned your reward and bonus.
I present to you this dagger.
It's an enchanted blade known as Suffathorn.
Its prick is deadly, I assure you.
Yes, you are quite an asset to this sanctuary.
In fact, I believe you are ready for advancement.
Oh God, what's happening?
I hereby appoint you slayer.
Big boss.
Well done.
I'm the doom slayer.
Now go, sound of Sithis.
Go and rest.
You'll need it.
Thank you.
Hail, my sister.
I'm a slayer.
I've been meaning to speak with you.
I'm the doom slayer.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I want to play the new doom so bad.
It looks so fun.
Have you played it yet?
It's funny because my two moods right now are fantasy life and doom.
It's awesome.
Waiting on a sail.
I think I'll wait for it to go on sail too.
I'm not gonna lie.
I might wait for it to go on sail too.
But it looks so fun.
My PC can't run it.
Oh, but your PC could run fantasy life.
And it's not the same, but it's pretty darn great.
It's free on game pass.
No kidding.
I love how we say that free on game pass when game pass is literally paid.
I must accept a contract.
No, no, no, no.
We're going to go to Anvil, but I kind of want to travel the roads, but it's like the furthest.
So it will travel from Kvatch, you know?
We'll travel from Kvatch since it's our first time.
First time in Japan, finally playing MGS.
What a great establishing cuts in.
For real, while watching sneaky ghost stealth in a closet.
Welcome to Japan.
Welcome, welcome.
I think it's this pathway up here.
Freemium.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're like, it's free on blank, but blank requires a subscription.
Not that I am, I, I do appreciate game pass quite a bit though, because Sometimes I'm not sure what to play.
And I'll just see what's, what's available on it, you know?
It's free with a star.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're going the right way.
We're going to lag a little bit since we're entering new territory.
Is that a guard?
Or a bandit?
Oops.
Damn, I got his toes.
I think that's a bandit.
Oh, come on.
Bandit Bowman.
Wow, he's got a lot of steel arrows.
Let's go.
Can I take that one back or...
Wait, how do you pick people up again?
Oh...
Uh...
Bro just stood there and took it.
Yeah.
Hold E.
Oh, that's...
There we go.
Okay.
Move your body.
No, no.
It's like...
Oh, come on.
So I did hit that!
I did hit him!
I think it just didn't register.
Lame.
Oh, no!
There's an oblivion portal here, too!
Okay, let's get my bow and arrow out just in case.
I'm gonna sneak.
Just in case there's some...
Freakish dudes around.
I mean, this is pretty fre...
This is pretty freakish.
I noticed this...
Oh, the bandit!
What were you doing?
Hmm.
Go be another hero.
After I get my house, maybe we will do oblivion portal again.
Gottshaw Inn.
Maybe we will do another portal.
Where is my horse?
I'll never know.
Portals are optional, but they have good loot.
Oh.
Hello?
Imperial Legion soldier?
Hello.
Hi!
Did you know that there's a portal, like, right out there?
What do you need?
I'm asking you.
Do you know?
Gray Fox.
That's my boss.
Carry on.
Oblivion portal in Elder Scrolls Oblivion?
Bravo Kojima!
He does it again.
In order to pick people up first, you gotta have some riz.
I think I have...
Riz.
Oh, this is about the...
Yeah, he was assassinated.
Yeah.
How do you do?
Is this...
Is this where you sleep?
No, sir.
It's not saying that I can't go into these rooms.
It's just saying that it's hard to.
I think...
I think I could probably do it.
I've got the riz.
Guys, we must continue onward to Anvil.
We're on a journey.
Why is it Kvatch...
Oh, I thought that was an imp.
Oh my gosh.
Why is it Kvatch the third?
No, I don't want to fast travel.
Imagine being a thief who can't pickpocket.
Surely you're not talking about me.
Some scratch mark.
Is it supposed to be...
Wow, it's so dusty in here.
It's supposed to...
Is it...
Is it supposed to be like a...
They got...
Burnt down, so...
What was that?
What's that?
Nothing?
Does he got gold?
No.
I am talking about you and don't call me Charlie.
I pickpocketed that guy.
What are you talking about?
Am I getting attacked or something?
I hear like something...
Sounds like...
Oh.
No.
Sounds like something's like blowing fire at me.
Oh.
Hmm.
Must have been the wind, yeah.
Okay.
You are guards.
You know, I once had a horse like that.
Oh ho.
Why did you take down the horse too?
Oh, maybe they took down the scamp.
Oh, he's empty.
You're...
They took down your horse?
Look at him.
He...
He wants to end it all.
He misses his horse so much.
It's my birthday today.
May I have a minto birthday song?
Ho ho.
I'm sorry.
I can't sing right now.
Actually, especially today.
I think my voice is too bad.
Wait, there's a second portal.
Wait, hold on.
No.
I'm so sorry.
I want to sing for you.
Happy birthday though.
Happy, happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
Portals everywhere, yeah.
Is that anvil?
Oh, sure.
Looks like it.
I wish I could mark where the portals are.
This is so sad.
This must be what I was hearing.
Are you okay?
Ma'am?
Ma 'am?
You got any rumors?
The Kvatch Oblivion Gate has been closed.
Don't you understand what that means?
We can beat the bastards.
Oh, you can get close to a market.
Carry on.
Help, there's no other s...
Dang it.
I killed him.
Oh.
There's three of them?
Three more?
Oh, shoot.
You saw me?
So much for being stealthy.
Where is he?
Oh, shoot.
The twang of the bow and scraping of arrow fletchings are quite familiar to you.
As a new journeyman marksman, you can now focus your vision to aim more precisely by holding...
Right click?
Wait, where?
Wait, where'd the other guys go?
Shoot.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, oh.
I have to aim?
Damn it.
That killed him though?
I think that should be all of them.
They're rolling.
And hands.
Sorry, I mean, I hope your voice gets on soon.
This will be my birthday wish.
Thank you!
I will sing you a happy birthday.
Another day.
Promise.
Even if it's delayed.
I'll sing you a happy birthday.
Okay.
Oh, my eyes.
Get my arrows back.
That one probably was eaten by the rocks.
Let's go to the other one and mark it too.
Oh, wait!
If I sleep...
I can...
get the upgrade.
Nice.
Let's sleep.
Wow, it's so...
Okay, we get it.
You're a portal.
Oh my god.
So much thunder.
We got the level up, baby.
Okay, so there's another portal over here.
I can now zoom.
This is huge!
I don't see no scamps.
I guess I was like so concerned about the sounds before.
Itina has learned the power of leading forward.
I was...
Those sounds I was hearing before that I thought someone was attacking me, they were attacking them.
If I had been quicker, I could have, uh...
I could have helped them.
Oh well.
Okay, I think that marked it.
Did it?
I think we marked it.
It's on the thing.
No, it's still not on the map.
Oh, it's gone now.
The portal is still there.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe if I try the other side.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we got it.
Meet the zoomer.
I'm zooming.
Okay.
Nice.
What's over here?
Is this, uh...
This looks like...
Oh, this looks like...
A gar-las-a-gea.
That's exactly what I was gonna say.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh my god, dog.
No.
Oh shoot.
Come on, don't...
Don't run.
Okay.
Very good.
He's got moves.
Oh, where am I?
Okay, I'm trying to get up back to the path.
And here we go.
Oh.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
Sorry, buddy.
He looks so...
There's no way I'm going in there.
He looks so lost.
Like he doesn't know what to do.
He has no purpose now.
Oh.
Who are you?
Is it necessary that you speak with me?
Sorry.
Oh.
Wait, who are you?
Are you allowed to be on this horse?
Wait, what are you doing?
Sorry, no time to talk.
I have to deliver these copies of the Black Horse Courier.
Have you heard of the Blackwood Company?
Read all about them.
Oh.
Okay.
Golly.
She's busy being a little lady over here.
Okay, we get it.
The portal.
We get it.
Oh, our beautiful town is like so ugly right now.
Read all about it.
Okay, I think we are far enough from the...
From the portal's influence.
Everyone's so rude in this game.
You know, I would be too.
If I wasn't sure if...
Who's friend or foe, you know?
Yeah, let's...
Maybe...
Well, I don't want to sleep here because it won't be free.
Takanashi Kiara?
What's wrong?
Welcome to the end.
A whole live English's myth?
If you ruin your answer, speak with Kristoff.
No way.
Where does our food come from?
The heartlands.
And the Nebunian Valley.
And Skingrad?
Great wines, cheeses, and tomatoes.
Tomatoes.
You too.
I didn't say anything.
I could open one of these doors and sleep without paying for it.
In fact, that's what I'll do.
I'm the hero of Kvatch.
I deserve this.
In my bed now...
Will they notice, or...
Just shut the door.
It's fine.
Waste of my time and my resources.
You've got my ear.
Let's hear it.
Have you heard about Kvatch?
They say that Daedra came from Oblivion and burned the whole city to the ground.
Oh no.
Without question.
What's the news from the other parts of Tamriel?
Nothing I'd like to talk about.
Using that reason a lot, hero.
What is it now?
I don't even know you, Ariel.
Good afternoon.
Ariel.
Dry.
Wait.
The ocean is where it's all at.
Do do do do.
Boop.
Go ahead.
I'm listening.
On Cyrodiil's northern border is the sparsely populated mountain wilderness called the Valeus Mountains.
What is it now?
So I've heard.
Can I sleep in this bed?
Damn.
I don't want to pay for a bed.
I'd rather just like find another bed.
We'll go to one of our guilds here.
I think.
We'll go to a guild.
Who died?
Oh my god.
Horse?
You dream about going up there.
Now that is a big mistake.
Just look at the world around you.
Right here on the ocean floor.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
I just saw you.
Sorry.
Oh shoot.
I didn't see you highwayman.
I'm the highwayman.
Sorry.
I really didn't see you there.
I don't...
I saw the uh...
I saw the chest and that's it.
I only thought about stealing.
And not about you doing.
An average chest.
Little mermaid watch along.
Do we need that?
Dog?
Is that a dog?
That's fine.
We're going to the haunted house.
Live action.
I watched the live action little mermaid on the plane.
I think you guys when I come back so...
So they typically update the um...
The...
The movie list monthly.
And I know because sometimes I'll go to Japan and when I come back it'll be a different month.
Like I'll...
You know, I'll go like towards the end of the month.
Like what's happening this time.
And I come back and it's a different month.
And the movie that I was watching on the way there is not on the plane anymore.
Did you ever get that?
Gop, gop, gop, gop, gop.
Who are you?
Oh my god.
I think I'm in trouble.
What's happening?
Make the liar?
Who is this guy?
But um...
I think next month the Minecraft movie will be on it for sure.
Wait, who is this guy?
No, no, no, I'm busy.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
I can't run anymore.
The man himself...
Oh, put down your...
My weapon, okay.
Why...
Where is he going?
Oh my god.
I'm almost there.
He has a mission.
Good golly, man.
I'm trying to catch up to him.
I really am.
He's just really stinking fast.
What the hell?
Okay.
I'm almost there.
Oh my gosh.
We're going to catch up to him.
Please!
Slow down!
I'm trying.
Oh my gosh.
I'm almost there.
I can...
Oh!
Myik knows much.
Tells some.
Myik knows many things others do not.
Why were you running?
Myik thinks his people are beautiful.
The Argonian people are beautiful as well.
They look better than ever before.
That's the rumors?
Why are you running?
But he's a liar.
Myik the liar.
You too.
And then he's going to take off again.
Where is he going?
You know what?
I think he's the main character of this story.
Myik provides different dev commentary every time.
What?
He's the best NPC.
You guys, I'm afraid we'll never see him again.
He's, he's gone.
He's gone for good.
I have to run all the way back.
He pops in here and there.
I see.
Myik.
Okay, I'll look forward to seeing him again.
He hangs out at different places.
Well, good thing we caught him when we did.
Oh, Myik.
I wish I had a horse.
I wish...
You got this.
Good job.
There he goes.
Oh, it's one of the lizards.
One of the lizards got through.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Yes.
Rumors?
The Kvatch Oblivion Gate has been closed.
Don't you understand what that means?
Liquidos, thank you.
Farewell, citizen.
She's programmed to seek out the nearest pair of calipers.
Wherever they may be.
What?
Speak.
Did you finish delivering your thing, lady?
All right, let's go get a haunted house, you guys.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Almost fast.
Oh, now you want to talk to me, huh?
Wait, wait.
Just please.
Wait, hold on.
He's in other games as well.
It's really cool to see you got him.
Oh, neat.
Sorry, no time to talk.
I have to deliver these copies of the Black Horse Courier.
Oh, she gave me another one.
Read all about it.
All right.
Haunted house.
Guys, will I see a ghost or...
What?
Oh gosh, I'm so excited.
I'm so excited.
I'm gonna walk in there and be like, Hey there, demons.
It's me.
Ya boi.
I see a ghost.
I see a ghost right now.
Gang.
Gang, gang, gang, gang, gang.
Darling.
An all-female gang of thieves has been recently plaguing Anvil with a very unique method of robbing.
They pick on only the men.
If you want to help us do something about it, go talk to Gogan and Melona.
Let's just say Gogan is intimately involved and leave it at that.
Ha ha.
It's unbelievable.
Oh, that's right.
There was a...
Right in the center of the city, nobody saw anything.
Makes you wonder about the competence of the guard, if you ask me.
There was the attack.
Everyone's been talking about it.
Any rumors?
Arvina Thelis is an odd one.
I've heard some strange noises coming from her basement.
What?
Wait.
Oh wait, it's an occupied place?
I see a ghost in the bottom right corner.
Goodbye.
You guys have such good sixth sense.
If you can see me all the time.
Or maybe I've just sucked so much life force from you guys that...
I'm all-powerful.
You know.
It's quiet here.
Oh, never mind.
Where did you come from?
The bushes?
Penniless...
Ovis?
We'll see about that.
Are you really penniless?
Yeah, he is.
I've been out of work since November.
Finally landed an interview today!
Cody!
It's amazing you got an interview, but...
Don't send me super chat them.
Is this the house?
No way.
Is this it?
Can I buy this?
Good luck, Cody!
You got this!
You got this.
Oh, whoa.
No-oh!
It's not an abandoned house!
A stranger.
You wear the shadows well, fellow thief.
You're my brother?
Who are you?
I...
Am the stranger.
Oh, that's your name!
That is all you need to know, that.
And I am no one to be trifled with.
Okay, stranger.
Sure.
Go down to the chapel and you can't miss him.
He'll be the one outside, ranting at passers-by.
About the thieves' guild.
I don't have time to gossip about the guild right now.
Okay.
I'm listening.
Leave me with a little persuading, alright?
Let's try.
Wait.
Why can't I... Why can't... It won't let me, actually.
No way.
It won't let me.
Aw, man.
Shadow hide you.
Myth or menace.
Oh, so this is all your stuff.
Okay.
Goodbye.
There's nothing else in here.
Your house is...
Disgusting.
Myth or menace.
Okay.
Well, clearly he's not part of that.
He's the stranger.
Arvina!
She said that lady was strange.
Alright, guys.
You're gonna have to point me to the direction of our new home.
You're gonna have to say...
Newheim the portly.
The inn behind you.
Go towards the inn?
Okay.
I wanna see...
Oh.
Is there anybody home?
I'm not trespassing.
I'm actually doing right.
Oh!
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
He's got some sick moves.
I'm Newheim.
Anvil Harbor Master.
I'm responsible for all harbor traffic, docks, duties, and fees in Anvil Harbor.
Ducks and duties?
Leave me alone.
Okay.
Sorry.
I...
I expected him to be a little...
More...
Bigger.
I don't know.
This is not...
Okay.
Chesson Sextius?
Of the Tootius Sextius household name?
No kidding!
Interesting!
Wow!
I didn't know!
Fox Glove.
I didn't know that they were a family!
Alright.
I'm looking for the N.
Oh, here, here.
Nope.
That's the Count's Arms.
N.
This looks like...
What is this?
Oh, the Mage's Guild.
I'm a part of that.
Hello.
The Fighter's Guild.
We could sleep at the Mage's Guild.
Oh, that was the N.
Oh, it was?
Count's Arms is an N.
Wow.
The more you know...
This?
Oh, wait.
But...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to go in.
It was happening.
Hello there.
Hello.
Wow, this place is fancy, though.
Wow.
Feels like I would actually get a good night's rest here, right?
Okay.
So, we're at the Inn.
Now...
Where do I go to get our haunted house?
Oh, there's a guy in there who will sell you the house.
Just kidding.
We turn around.
Hello there.
Oh.
Greetings to you.
Oh, goodbye.
Didier Ormalee, a ship's clerk.
At present, I'm spending my time in gold on the pleasures of the Gold Coast.
Okay.
You don't seem like you'll sell me a...
A house.
Hello, good...
You wouldn't happen to be in the market for a home, would you?
Yes!
If you are.
I just happen to be selling a manor located right here in Anvil.
Oh, yes.
Tell me more.
Yes.
I'm selling my grandfather's house.
Beneris Manor.
If you're interested, I could let you have it for a modest sum.
Okay.
I have to sell it soon as I have pressing matters elsewhere.
You're welcome to take a look at it.
It's located across the street from the chapel.
Once you buy, you get the key to the front door and the deed of ownership.
That's the deal.
Would you like to buy it now?
I haven't even seen it.
Wait, it's 5,000 gold.
How much do I have?
Well, I'll be here every day from noon until midnight.
Let me know if you change your mind.
Noon until midnight.
Don't you have a home?
Why don't you live here?
Okay, let's go check it out.
How much do I have?
How much gold do I have?
How can I tell?
1.3...
Oh, I see it.
Does he take a loan?
How are you?
Across from the...
Wait.
Where's the...
I'm lost.
Gosh.
Taking pennies.
Taking one gold, one gold is doing me nothing, you know?
Across from...
So...
Here?
Maybe?
Oak and hole?
Uh...
This is not a house.
Do some dungeon runs.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, come on!
They won't even let me see inside.
Nooo!
Maybe there's a...
Way I can break in.
It's my home!
My soon to be home!
Aw, man.
It's a big house.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It has a romantic balcony and everything.
Where I can just wistfully...
Uh...
Wistfully hope...
That someday...
I'll look like this lady.
Just sit and...
You know...
Ponder...
Look to the sea...
Be a hot mermaid...
Only 3700 gold to go.
Let's go sleep in the mage's guild.
Hmm...
I know people have told me...
How to get...
Gold fast in this game, but...
Oh my gosh.
Sparky!
It's you.
Hi.
You don't know me!
Alright then, I'm listening.
Thank you, we're homeless.
I'm sorry!
Let's go sleep.
But yeah, I can't remember what people told me.
What was the best way?
Oh, I can't steal that?
But I'm a member!
Why can't I have this...
This soul gem for me to...
Wait, why can't I take these?
Oh, alchemy.
Guilt missions are a normal way to make money.
Normal.
Hello, where's your beds?
Everyone's chomp-chomping.
What is it?
This is a library.
Maybe through here.
Door very hard.
Oh!
It didn't...
It wasn't red.
Very hard on my butt.
Oh!
See?
We found the bed.
Easy peasy.
Save for a good amount of time.
Level seven.
Okay.
Whoa!
We have so many...
Okay.
So agility...
A lot.
We're almost all the way...
Agile.
Gosh, we're so good.
What was I putting in also?
I guess it looks like...
Into speed?
Speed?
What's endurance?
Uh...
An endurance, maybe.
Maybe like that.
I don't mind...
I think maybe I was doing some strength.
Oh wait.
With my bow.
Maybe not speed then.
I was gonna say...
I don't mind being faster, but...
I think we need to be stronger.
Oh wait, no.
Wait, which is...
Wait, I was reading...
Oh, it's a...
It was...
Agility I was reading.
I'm stupid.
Okay.
This...
This one does let you carry more weight.
Hmm...
Uh...
I think we've been putting stuff into it.
Yeah, whatever.
Oh.
Hey.
Well met.
Well met...
Oh, what was that?
Was that that?
I didn't knock that over.
That was freaky.
Oh, I could've slept in here.
With a...
Hot Maiden.
Weakness to disease.
I like that.
Oh, come on.
She wants me in the bed.
Hello, associate.
Hello.
To earn a recommendation from me, you need simply prove you are able-bodied and prepared to learn something in the process.
I played their cover of Break Stuff?
The sillier, softer one over the intercom at work, and someone literally told an employee they assumed it was some ghost?
What?
Huh?
The Mage's Guild has made more than a few enemies since necromancy was banned.
Why is necromancy banned?
Farewell.
Crystal ball.
That looks fancy.
Guys, I need to...
I need to make money.
I need...
What should I...
What should I do?
Sell...
Things.
Like, should I start taking some of this stuff and then sell it?
I could take all this stuff...
And sell it.
Thank you so much for the Redirect!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go sell all these things.
It's free real estate.
Yeah, exactly.
And they're worth 50.
Yes.
These ones we can't take.
Unfortunately.
Thank you guys for the gift!
Thank you!
Thank you Ducky!
Thank you Rock for Rubber!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
You think I can take these things?
Block.
Picking.
Do I go?
Thank you for the vibe.
Good to thank you.
Easy.
Enthralling presence.
What does that mean?
Wait.
What did I just grab?
Absorb mysticism on touch.
Absorb.
Absorb it.
Absorb strength on touch.
How do I use these?
Like, how do I actually...
Charm on target.
How do I...
In the spell tab.
Alchemy.
There is no spell tab.
There's alchemy.
You just equip them.
No kidding?
Oh.
I can only have one equipped at a time.
No?
At the very top.
I still don't see spells.
Magic?
Ah, here we go.
Ah...
Open easy lock on target.
Easy locks are easy.
Can only be used once.
They have a one time use.
Sunshine welcome to membership thank you.
Usually it's just best to sell scrolls they are worth a lot and have one use.
Is that true?
True.
Let's see.
It doesn't say how much they're worth.
This one's worth a good amount.
Hmm.
Oh.
Let's go find... Wait, what time is it?
6 a.m.
Okay.
The place... We gotta go find a store.
And sell things.
Maybe.
Also...
Look at the faces of the dead.
I wouldn't go in there unless you have a strong stomach.
We have orders to leave everything just the way it was until the investigation into the chapel attack is finished.
Oh my god.
You scared me.
It's baffling.
How anyone could have gotten in and out of there without being seen by our patrols is beyond me.
Maybe that prophet is right.
Some kind of unholy scared me.
You scared the heck out of me.
The prophet.
He preaches most of the day across the street from the chapel.
Yeah, I know.
I was looking at him.
I used to think he was crazy.
But now he seems to be making some kind of sense.
I hope that doesn't mean I'm going crazy now.
Classic oblivion jump scare.
Haha.
Captain Dougal's rumored treasure has to be true.
I wonder if the first count of anvil found it.
Treasure?
Haha.
This is your future.
Evil has returned.
Treasure?
And the nine need a champion.
Oh, well, well.
A wayward son returning to the church.
What do you want with me?
What are you doing?
This is only the beginning.
Umaril has returned as foretold by Pelinal Whitestrake in his dying breath.
You're just saying names.
You're just saying things.
Tell me who attack- Just tell me who attacked the chapel.
Do you understand nothing?
The blood speaks.
I can read the ancient runes if you cannot.
Umaril.
I can read it too, okay?
By the eternal power of Umaril, the mortal gods shall be cast down.
A curse upon Umaril's ancient foes.
And a threat.
A threat?
How do we stop Umaril?
He looks so sad.
Why not?
No elves allowed in this quest?
Without a champion, the gods are powerless to act.
But who among us is worthy to wield the divine crusader's weaponry?
I will... I will... Among us... I don't know who will stop Umaril.
Nor do... I.
Oh, my people!
Who will save you from destruction?
Is there none now worthy to be your crusader?
Wait a minute.
Think on this.
What happened here is...
Is that real?
Like, I actually wouldn't have been able to do it?
Let me in, man.
Greetings, Bosma.
Oh, you can.
Jam.
Wow, they didn't even clean this up.
Yikes.
Oh, my God!
They just left the people here!
They've...
Oh, my God.
Oh, shoot.
I'm stealing.
No one's in here.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Am I on fire?
What hurt me?
I only need one key.
Oh!
They spelled ancient runes.
Oh, my gosh!
Whoa!
I like how taking the plants is stealing.
Whoa.
No, I was joking.
Oh, what the heck?
You guys can't tell me things.
I'll believe you.
Why can't I go in here?
I'm just gonna go.
Oh, that was an actual ghost.
Um...
What about this one?
That was...
That was a ghost.
Finally, I've seen a ghost in the game.
Why are these areas off-limits, huh?
Mass death from overeating strawberry jam.
Don't eat the jam.
This book is worth a hundred bucks!
Frostfall.
Wait.
I just gained something.
Oh.
Conjuration.
Ooh.
Yoink.
The Amulet of Kings.
Hmm.
You guys are selling some stuff, huh?
Um...
Can I open this one?
Yeah.
Nice.
Uh...
This one's worth 25.
We'll sell some stuff soon.
We gotta go find the...
150 bucks!
They're worth a fortune!
Good find.
Ooh.
That one had pictures.
Hmm-hmm.
The Argonian account.
Sweet rule!
That looks delicious.
She's rich.
I will be.
And then I'll spend it all on a house.
Just like real life.
Nobody's down here.
What's so bad?
Nobody's using any of this stuff anyway.
So it's fine if I take it.
You already sell the statues to the guy who...
Buys them for double the value.
Uh, I didn't know...
A guy like that existed.
So...
I don't think so.
There's nothing else in here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
It was, uh...
Undercroft.
Does he guard the place?
Or...
Can I get him with...
He's got hair.
Ha-ha.
Oh.
There's a guy.
Oh, shoot.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha I'm wondering if that green milk would taste good drinking out of it.
I tried to find the creeper milk.
I went to a couple different grocery stores and they didn't have it.
And then...
Well, you know what they had instead?
Enderman milk.
So I got that.
Hi there.
Okay, where is a store?
What are you doing here?
Have pity on an old war veteran.
This is an establishment.
Hello.
Hi there.
Is it purple?
You would think, right?
It's such a wasted opportunity.
It's just chocolate milk.
Which I don't know the last time I had chocolate milk, so I was kind of excited.
But I was like, it's just chalky milk.
It's so lame.
When they even made the creeper milk green.
They, like, actually attempted.
I got a pumpkin.
And now I'm over encumbered.
Pumpkin.
I wish to...
Release you from my inventory.
Where is he?
JK Elemental Pumpkin.
Oh, I ate it?
Greetings, Bosmer.
I don't see any stores in here.
And the lighthouse.
Main gate.
What's no rest for the wicked?
What is my quest currently?
Oh, I get another...
Maybe I just keep doing contracts for the brotherhood.
I don't know.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Abandoned house.
What are the peacemakers?
The peacemakers?
The manor?
Hmm.
That's a weapon shop.
Ah.
So far the brotherhood seems to give you gear.
They have been giving me money too.
Albeit, not a lot.
But I have gotten some cents.
I got a hundred gold last time.
You will get a cool bow.
I want that.
Fighter's Guild is quickish gold too?
Still okay.
How are you?
Oh, this is the castle.
Whoa!
Right now I'm still...
Even if I don't get the house right away.
I've still been enjoying myself with exploration.
Sorry, I thought that was dookie on the ground.
Oh, here we go.
What's the fu...
Oh, fu...
Fox.
Oh.
Have you heard any word about the other provinces?
There we go.
Oh, I can't go in there.
Just kidding.
Here we go.
Norbert?
I'm Norbert Lels.
I let my merchandise speak for itself.
Look around.
If you see something you like, we'll talk about a price.
Okay.
We'll see.
How much do you like me?
No.
You do me too much honor.
Uh-oh.
I messed up.
I spent a minute.
Oh, gosh.
You win this one.
Blah, blah, blah.
Oh.
What a bore.
Uh-oh.
I messed up.
You think that's funny?
Uh-oh.
Let's try again.
What a dumb joke.
It's a good joke, actually.
But...
That's enough.
Oh, shoot.
Really now?
Blah, blah, blah.
No!
What a bore.
Oh, my gosh.
I went down crazy.
Uh...
What a wonderful compliment.
Don't make me laugh.
I won't fight.
What a dumb joke.
Okay.
I...
I've saved that one.
Okay.
You're full of it.
Sorry, I don't get...
Please.
I mean...
I won't fight you.
Okay, we're at 60.
We're at 60.
Uh...
You've got a point.
What a dumb joke.
Please.
You're a big, fat liar.
64?
Sorry, I don't get it.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna...
Oh, shoot.
Really now?
You're a big...
You win this one.
67!
I can't do anymore.
Okay, dang it.
We maxed to 67.
Only quality goods for sale here.
What can I interest you in?
What do you have?
A whole lot of junk.
That's what it is.
All right.
Maybe we could get...
52% of value on my books.
Let's sell all these books that I recently acquired.
What the heck is this Sufferthorn?
When did I get that?
It's worth so much.
When did I get this?
Where are my books?
Do I have to go to the Thieves Guild?
Oh, from the Dark Brotherhood.
It's my special dagger.
Wait, the books aren't stolen.
They weren't read.
Uh-oh.
You need a fence.
What's that mean?
What do you mean?
They were read.
No.
Oh.
Oh, the ones from the church.
Yeah.
Those were read.
You can't do anything for me.
Farewell.
Yep.
Where was the guy that I could sell to?
There was, like, one guy in particular.
Oh.
Can I...
Is it...
Is it okay?
If I...
Yeah?
Okay, cool.
Fence and Bruma.
Thank you.
Alright, let's go there, then.
There was a special guy in Bruma that we could sell to.
Titanic moment.
Oh.
Sorry, that was me trying to sing.
Hi there.
Oh.
Hello.
I was trying to sing.
Don't worry about it.
Who was it here?
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
Let me go talk, too.
Let's go find...
Oops.
Ouch.
You okay?
Eating?
Oh.
You look so...
Hi there.
You look frightening.
He's at a dive bar downtown.
What?
What a house for sale.
No, no, no.
An eye on the prize.
Eye on the prize.
Maybe he's an Olavs.
Today's your lucky day.
Whoa.
So let's hear it.
You do not belong in me.
What do you mean?
I'm Balin.
Oh, Balin.
I loved you, old man.
Oh, I killed your...
I loved you.
But I couldn't protect you.
Oh, Balin.
Not normally a big fan.
She can spin a yarn.
That's for sure.
Be seeing you.
His face.
Hello.
Hi there.
How are you?
I see you are with the gray fox.
Do you need a fence?
Like...
Shh.
Yes.
Yes, I do.
Yes, I need a fox.
All thieves guild members have sworn loyalty to him.
If there is such a thing as a guild master, he's it.
Wait, I can't wear Bruma.
Bruma is a perfect town for a Nord man of leisure.
Bracing mountain air, good food and drink, and lively Nord fellowship.
Um...
Where can I...
What do you want to know?
Oh, wait, you are my guy.
Just kidding.
I can handle some...
Okay.
Do you like me?
All right.
Oh.
She does not like me.
You should be ashamed.
Is that so?
Please, I'm embarrassed.
Really?
Interesting.
Okay.
35 for plus 19 seems pretty good.
Hmm.
Now it's plus 17.
What happened?
Let's try again.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, this is not good.
Remarkable.
Not funny.
Not even a little.
What a wonderful...
Oh, please.
Ugh.
No, you do me too much honor.
What a great story.
You should be ashamed.
Oh, please.
I'm not getting anywhere.
Oh, dang.
Oh, here we go.
That's...
Oh, please.
Oh, no.
No.
That was the best I could have done, I think.
Oh, please.
It's less effective, the higher their affection is.
I see.
Maybe I should have gone for it first then, huh?
We're at 50.
Let's see.
Well done.
You should be ashamed.
Ugh.
Um.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, here.
You should be ashamed.
Nice.
Really now.
You're such a charm.
Is that so?
Really?
Interesting.
63.
What a wonderful compliment.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Remarkable.
You should be ashamed.
Oh, please.
64.
Okay.
Ugh.
Come on.
Not funny.
Not even a little...
That's just talk.
No, you...
Remarkable.
70!
We made it to 70, guys.
Let's go!
Minto, they hate your jokes.
It's okay.
Look at...
He's been smirking this whole way.
He...
He actually...
He's just being too nitty.
You know?
Shut up, guys.
Don't...
Stop talking about 69.
We have to get to 70.
Should I try one more time?
I think I should.
Oh, just kidding.
I can't.
But I could bribe him.
What a thoughtful gift.
You're welcome.
Okay.
I see.
Oops.
Oh.
Yeah.
Now barter.
My favorite customer.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Maybe like 50% of the value.
I like how we're just doing this in front of everybody.
That's so...
That works too.
I could sell anything that I want, actually.
Now that I think about it.
Because...
He'll buy it.
You know?
He loves you.
He does.
I'm going to sell this...
This one.
I don't need it.
He took it for 50%.
Oh my god.
And all of these.
These were...
Yeah, I took all of these too.
Yeah, yeah.
An excellent bargain.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
I think I should haggle for better.
Um...
I don't even know why I have this.
Oh wait.
This is for potions and stuff, no?
Uh, let's see.
Okay, so you guys said to...
Face...
This one seems good though, no?
Invisibility on self.
That one I think I'll keep around.
These ones.
Here we go.
I can't make that deal, even for you.
Okay.
What about 53?
A fine transaction.
Yes!
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
That's more than I would believe.
You got a great deal there.
That seems a fair price.
Nice.
Nice!
What else do I have that is stolen?
But I haven't been able to sell off.
Let's see.
I have a couple things.
Did I take this because it was expensive?
It was a hundred.
Yeah?
Okay.
That's a fair deal.
Yeah, that's a fair deal.
Let's see.
What else do I got?
That's...
That's expensive.
I guess I can do it by price.
Let's see.
Okay.
We can sell some of these, I suppose.
Fortifying health on self.
Chameleon.
What does chameleon do?
Bronze amulet is stolen.
So is this ring.
So is this ruby.
Actually, let's get rid of these.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
I think I grabbed that from the...
That's more than I'd usually pay.
He loves me.
Don't sell the statue.
No, no, no.
Yeah, I didn't plant the...
This one, right?
No, no.
I didn't want to sell it.
Anything else stolen?
Oh, here we go.
Bronze amulet.
That's more than I'd usually pay.
I'll sell this too.
Weakness to disease.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
I'll sell this one too.
Yeah, I do, buddy.
Yeah, I do.
I've been...
I've been taking so much stuff.
Got anything else?
My repair hammers I can use.
We'll get rid of the wall.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
Got anything else?
House upper wall hangings.
Well, that's not even worth anything.
Gee, you sure you can handle easy lock?
Chainmail is so heavy.
Chainmail is not so heavy.
Let's see.
What's the heaviest thing we got?
Don't say chainmail.
It's like...
It's okay heavy.
It's not so bad, actually.
I feel like I can sell a lot of these clothes, can't I?
Chameleon is invisibility that doesn't break when you attack or pick up or interact.
It's very good.
Basically, like passive stealth.
And at 100, you can't ever be seen by anyone.
Oh, I see.
Let's sell some of our clothes.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
My fur don't much.
What's a snowball tone?
I don't remember.
We're at 22.
Where's the chainmail?
I'll sell it.
I just don't know where it is.
Chainmail.
My greaves.
Goodbye.
I think I can move this item for you at that price.
My gauntlets.
Goodbye.
That's a good deal.
Thank you.
Hmm.
I don't even know what I'm wearing right now.
I don't even know.
What's a Harada?
List of death.
Hmm.
He is the guy who made Tekken.
You're so right.
You are so right.
I'm gonna sell this steel short sword because we got the Sufferthorn.
So, I'm gonna sell this.
Since we got that.
That freed up a lot of our inventory, too.
Almost over a hundred.
Sell, sell, sell.
And now we just need...
We need less than 3,000.
About 2,700.
And we will be able to buy...
We will be able to buy...
The house.
I'm glad that's done.
I need a nap.
Do yawn.
Rumors?
Poor Arnora.
Seems her boyfriend, Jorunder, has stolen some gold from her and left her penniless.
Now he's in jail and she's destitute.
He says it so excitedly.
He looks like he's about to lose his hair, too.
Shadow hide you.
We're not hiding from anybody.
Look at all...
All these people are...
Staring at us.
I've reached my goal.
I've fenced over 50 gold worth of goods.
I should go and see Arman sometime.
Yes!
Let's make that my active voice.
Hi.
I'm Olga.
I'm a bard and a speechcraft trainer.
Hanmund is my live-in partner.
No offense, but I don't want to hear about any Mara Mother Mild and chapel family business.
Mara Mother Mild.
Hanmund and I live together in the old Nord way.
Good enough for my fa and ma and good enough for me.
Nice.
But using my mint mug is so cute!
Thank you!
Every time I drink right-handed, it lines up...
Stop, don't say that!
Don't say that!
You too!
I get embarrassed too.
You designed it that way.
I know, but it's...
You bit the book!
I know, but...
It's like...
You're supposed to be...
It's supposed to spook you more than anything.
You're supposed to be like...
Where did this slip-stick stain come from?
My house must be haunted!
Like that.
Golly!
I'm right here!
Greetings!
What exactly do you require of me?
Nothing.
Actually, I require a bathroom.
I gotta go pee.
You guys, here's some oblivion.
ASMR.
Watch the people as they people.
Watch them walk.
Watch them live.
Watch them do their little thing.
I'll be right back.
That'll be a rip-up.
Spin...
Oh!
Well, welcome back.
Thank you!
What a lovely couple!
Go ahead!
Please!
Of course!
I can't say your name.
Poor Arnora.
Seems her boyfriend Jirunder has stolen some gold for her and left her penniless.
Now he's in jail and she's destitute.
Why do they all say the same thing?
Goodbye.
Oh.
How are you?
Damn.
I'm sorry for you.
Surrutan, I'm sorry for you.
I'm Surrutan.
Surrutan.
I'm the proud owner of Nova Roma.
A little piece of Heartland Empire here in the Lofty Gerald's.
I see.
What else?
What are you... are you gonna talk about Nora?
Don't get on Jaskar's bad side.
You'll likely get a fireball in your face for your troubles.
Whoa.
Uh, Jirunder.
Our Nora and Jirunder were once a happy couple.
The whole town is talking about these two.
I hear that he took all of their money and stashed it after he committed a robbery.
Wait, where did he stash it?
He was going to skip town on our Nora, but got arrested before making good on his escape.
Now she has no money left at all.
Poor thing.
Is she destitute?
Is she sa...
Oh, two sides of the coin.
Take care.
Wait, what is this?
So I realize, guys, one of my meetings is in 20 minutes.
So I might have to call it soon.
Though I want to go to the thieves first.
I heard that Nora of Bruma is looking for some help recovering some money.
Oh, I need the money, actually.
So yeah, I need the money more than...
Wait, what is that?
Where spirits have lease.
Oh
yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
So let's go to the thieves.
Wait, what is this?
Here.
Even in a fantasy world, we can't afford a mortgage.
Unfortunately, I, you know, as a ghost...
Okay.
So it's kind of complicated.
Like, I can choose wherever I want to haunt.
As long as it's not being...
Rent haunted by...
Someone else, you know?
But at the same time...
Puny.
You know, it's like...
There's also rent.
But it's also easier to find.
No, I could just pick, like, anywhere that I want to haunt.
I'm glad you stopped by.
I have a situation that you might be able to help with.
A situation, eh?
What's that?
The gray fox has asked me to take care of a problem.
You need the money?
I'm putting you on it.
Hieronymus Lex actually collected taxes from everyone living here on the waterfront.
Your job is to recover those taxes.
Are you up for it?
Yes.
Who's Hieronymus Lex?
He is a fool of a captain in the Imperial Watch.
He's a real law and order type.
Oh yeah, I forgot the Thieves Guild are like Robin Hood people.
That's why I like being with the Brotherhood.
The gray fox has led our guild for over 300 years now.
He has always guaranteed protection to the poor of the waterfront.
Sure, I'll do it.
Good.
Find out where he's keeping the taxes and bring them to me.
I'll also need the tax records of what each citizen paid so we can return it.
Okay, cool.
Untaxing the poor.
Shadowhide you.
This way.
He's keeping it.
The chapel attacked.
Now...
Oh my god!
...take yourself here the first time.
If you get near that ship, you'll end up dead.
I didn't even talk to you!
You came up to me!
Sure.
Have you heard any word about the other problem?
Oh my gosh!
We're getting jump scared left and right.
She's so blue.
That's how I like him, baby.
Over here?
Trends?
No.
Where am I?
Is it behind?
Hello.
I don't want you to listen to me.
Here.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
It's not illegal for us to go in here.
Who is the...
Who is the destitute?
Oh my god!
P...
P?
This direction.
Over here?
What is it, citizen?
Oh my goodness.
We're heading all over the place.
P?
Don't miss your meeting.
Don't worry.
Oh, it's taking me to a whole other...
My horse!
Oh my god!
You've been here the whole time!
Wait.
It was taking us all the way out...
Untaxing...
Oh, I was on the wrong thing...
I think.
Oh, come on.
Ah, the wrong quest selected.
Okay.
What is it, citizen?
Nothing.
I'll go until I can't anymore.
For playing.
It's just so much fun.
I can't stop.
Especially because it's been so long since I played.
I don't want to play anything off stream.
Maybe, I don't...
Like...
If you guys are okay with me, like maybe...
Grinding...
What's it called?
Dungeons and stuff.
I don't know.
I don't know what would be good.
Speak.
They talk to me like I'm a dog.
Oh, here.
Peek.
What is it, citizen?
Oh.
Can you guys leave?
You have my ear.
Save me the quest.
You're the player of my air call.
Well, I don't want to like...
You guys are missing anything cool off screen.
I don't know.
Speak.
I think there's a guy talking to me from up there.
Okay, they're asleep.
Perfect.
Again?
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Loud root.
Okay.
He's average.
I think my pickpocketing has gone up.
I found the tax records.
Now to get them back to Armand in the waterfront district.
Nobody heard a thing.
I don't know how people sleep with the nerd roots around.
It's actually crazy.
I don't want to get too greedy.
But like...
What if I just look around a little bit, you know?
I don't want to...
You know, what if someone comes up here?
Are they gonna notice that I was all the way downstairs?
Or that they went up...
That I went up, you know?
I guess we'll find out.
They don't even care.
Wait, they don't even care.
Let's go.
In and out.
Easy peasy.
And I get to finish the quest.
You have my ear.
They're on break.
They can't be bothered.
Ear thief.
I stole your ear.
I stole your taxes.
All right.
Wait.
Where are you?
It's 3 a.m.
Wait.
Where are you?
Mister.
Uh...
Mister?
Oh, he has to be here at midnight.
That's right.
Okay, I'll just stand here for...
For 20 hours, I guess.
Oh, he has to be here at midnight.
Gosh, a whole lot of s...
Being a thief is...
Kind of boring work, huh?
Oh my god.
Is that him?
What?
Have you recovered those taxes?
Yeah, I did it.
And you were gone, you lazy.
Ah, the gray fox will be very pleased.
We will make sure this gets back to the people.
Gray fox will be pleased?
Can you believe that fool even bothered to collect this ultra sum?
How much are you gonna pay me?
Yeah, right?
You can keep it.
Oh.
I merely wanted the watch to know they went too far.
I think it's time to promote you to foot pad.
Congratulations on your new guild rank.
Okay, but how much more are you also giving me for that?
Any more?
No?
That's it?
I kept 50 gold and that's it?
The guild has received a request to obtain a unique statuette.
It is a bust of Laphasa Indaris, the recently slain Countess of Chainhall.
You will be paid a modest sum.
Thank you for the supertie.
Thank you.
Do you want this job?
Modest sum.
Yes, I'll take it.
Excellent.
Bring it back to me once you have it.
Okay.
The elfin maiden.
Shadowhide you.
Crime doesn't pay.
Well, it does in this.
I've reached my goal.
A fence over 100 golds worth of goods.
I should go see Armand.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Good to see you again.
Oh, his head.
Uh...
If you want luxury, there's nowhere better than the Tiber Septim Hotel.
Um...
Shadowhide you.
Oh, it's the job I just took.
Okay, okay.
Well, guys...
Uh, will this go away though?
I wonder.
Hmm.
Because I've already done it.
Huh.
Have a good time in Japan!
I hope you can get everything you want done and looking forward to see everything you're cooking.
Thanks for your loot!
Thank you!
Oh, ask about Gray Fox again.
Good to see you again.
All right, and then I have to go.
He's been around for hundreds of years.
I have to go.
I've heard tell that he is immortal.
I don't know about that, but he sure ain't normal.
Shadowhide you.
Oblivion portals could be good for grinding off stream.
They tend to be very samey and drop good loot.
Ah, maybe I'll try that then.
Take your door go!
Thank you!
All right, guys!
This is fun!
Oh, look!
His head is melting because of the fire.
Oh my gosh, you scared me!
Puny!
Okay.
Thank you, kind lady.
You're gonna get some shoes now, right?
Next time I see you, you better be wearing some shoes, puny.
Puny jump scare.
He looked like he was coming out there to murder me.
But, um, yeah.
I think this was good.
We made some good progress.
We killed some people.
We stole from some people.
My life of crime is...
Gosh, it's...
I'm dead, but I've never felt so alive.
Take so thank you!
Yeah.
Did lots of crime.
Lots of crime.
And next time, for sure.
We will get my house.
We will get my house for sure.
And I still gotta kill those other people.
Actually, though.
Wait, doesn't that guy pay like a thousand gold?
To kill those three people?
Wait.
That's a great one to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do that.
Yeah, Glarthor.
Taking Glarthor's quest will make you rich.
Okay.
Yeah, and then we can rob Glarthor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, Glarthor, next stream for sure.
Next stream for sure is Glarthor and the Murderous Pact.
The death list.
Um, but I gotta get going.
So, I'm gonna save like I am.
Let's do a new save.
And, uh...
Yeah!
Thank you, guys.
I'll see you if I see you tomorrow when I collab with...
With Koyo.
I don't know yet about stream my POV.
Like I said, it might be...
Depending on what game we play.
Because it might be like a one POV kind of thing.
But it's also pretty early for me.
But of course, I will tweet about it.
When will you be back?
Uh...
I will be back June...
5th?
June 5th.
Yes.
I think.
That's when I get back.
So, this actually might be my last stream until...
I get back.
I already miss you guys.
But, uh...
It will be...
It will be very busy for me.
So, I thought about streaming while I was there.
But, honestly...
Because, originally, I was only having one thing.
One reason to go.
And then it turned into a lot more.
So, I was like, I won't have time to stream.
Um...
Let me just...
So, yeah.
Um...
So, unfortunately...
I can't...
I can't stream while I'm there.
But, like I said, I'll do some...
Twitter spaces and things like that.
Stream's over, but I'll just go here.
Safe travels.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much, you guys.
Take care of yourself.
Thank you, guys.
I feel like I haven't streamed so much.
I feel so bad.
Since I haven't been streaming so much lately.
Uh...
I'm sorry.
But, hopefully, it all...
Pays off.
Don't feel bad.
I can't help it.
Literally can't help it.
Okay.
But yeah, I gotta get going.
I will see you guys another day!
Another day!
I don't know when.
Unless it's tomorrow.
See ya.
Okay, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Until next time!
See you guys later!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye!